Your favorite shoe company now only has 200 pairs of shoes in stock. Shoes are
selling fast because of the sale. If the company increases its shoe inventory by
25%, how many pairs of shoes will the company have? So the company is going to
be running out of shoes. If the company doesn't get any new pairs of shoes,
they'll have a 100% of their inventory. Their current inventory is 200, so
they'd have a 100% of 200. I know that as a decimal, a 100% is just 1. I divide
by a 100 and move the decimal place left, so, I have 1 times 200. The company
doesn't want this. If they just have 100% of the shoes, the inventory won't
change and they'll run out of shoes. So, in the last problem, we had to decrease
our percentage, because we had a percent off, but this time the company wants to
increase their percentage. Let's see if you can figure out what percentage of
the pairs of shoes you actually want to find.